[Music]
hey everyone how's it going hope you are
well so today it's been a long time
coming but I'm doing a what's on my desk
video I'm really happy with how my desk
setup is right now so I thought I'd
share with you what are all the things
that I've been using on a day to day
basis oh and if you're new here because
maybe the algorithm recommended me do hi
welcome thanks so much for being here my
name is Mai Yuko and on this channel I
make videos about what life is like as a
software engineer living in Silicon
Valley and my goal is to help you all
find your way through the tech industry
and if that's something that you're into
then consider subscribing right here I
would love your subscription and we feel
super honored to be one of your mini or
few or whatever kind of person you are
with your YouTube soups your friends
would say really that oh one last thing
I've got my first ever merch I'll talk
about it more at the end of the video so
stay tuned alright so let's talk about
what's on my desk so I'm gonna be
talking about my home desk right here I
have a desk at work but this is the desk
where I chose everything and I like
spending time here so this is the one
that I'm going to go over all right so
let's get this thing on the road so the
very first thing that I wanted to talk
about is the desk itself I have the
Jarvis bamboos standing desk and this is
something that I bought within the last
year after upgrading from my college
IKEA desk that I'd had for like eight
years so I was introduced to standing
desks through my last couple employers
and I really like the fact that you can
both sit and stand I found that if I sit
all day then my lower back and my leg
her and then if I stand all day than my
legs hurt and so kind of being able to
go back and forth between the two maybe
I change every hour and a half has been
really good and very flexible for me
it's also not outrageously expensive I
think I got this for like $500 I want to
say which for a desk that I'm going to
keep for 10 years and spend a lot of
time at and it sits and stands like
that's really good when you're buying
the Jarvis Jesse and basically configure
everything about it so I got the 16 by
30 inch bamboo top desk as well as the
white legs and the programmable key
thingy for the sit stanton functionality
and I also got some hooks to put some
headphones on which are a really nice
touch this is kind of my favorite
scenario of a sit-stand desk because I
love the large tabletop and then also I
like the fact that it just remembers
what height it needs to be at so that I
can be honest with myself and it's
always perfect every time that I sit or
stand it's just convenient and I really
enjoy it so nice on the docket are two
new additions for my best that I've been
really enjoying these two I've gotten as
gifts from Logitech and I love them
they're so good and the first of which
is my mouse which is the Logitech MX
master 3 so I used to use the Apple
Magic Mouse which I really liked
but then this mouse has a couple of key
features that I really really like that
I think sets it apart from other mice
the first of which is that the charging
port is right here which means that you
can use it while it's charging the
battery life is super good its USBC it's
just very pragmatic and very useful it
never gets in the way so the other thing
that I really like is that you can use
this mouse with up to 3 devices which
are super light because I have three
devices ones my personal computer ones
my youtube computer and the other one is
my work computer and instead of having
three different mice just having one and
being able to switch between them is so
easy also Bluetooth is just a pain to
work with and so just being able to
switch between it easily through the
hardware is just so good and the last
thing which is I think what makes
Smouse so popular is that you can
program all of the keys on this except
for the clicking ones and you can do
that per application I mean there's a
lot of other program a little mice out
there but this one just makes sense like
there's not too many keys it makes sense
it feels good in the hand and the fact
that you can program them per
application is a game-changer I've
programmed this one specifically for
Premiere Pro and Xcode and that's been a
game changer my workflow is way quicker
and way smoother I mean it's basically
like hotkeys on a mouse and being able
to do that on this thing is so nice it
also looks really good too which I'm
pretty happy about and it's slightly
ergonomic and so my hand and feels good
using it a night don't get tired from it
so really good Mouse so the next one
that works kind of in conjunction with
the mouse is the Logitech MX keys
keyboard which mine is running out of
battery but the battery life is also
really good on this and I like this for
a lot of the same reasons that I like
the mouse this things mean that you can
connect this with up to three devices
and all the keys are programmable I also
realize if I hold it up like this it
looks like I'm holding a boombox except
it's a keyboard I'm also someone that
really likes having a numpad and
sorrowed the fact that it comes with
that it's just like an added bonus so I
was actually a little bit skeptical
using this keyboard because it's not a
split keyboard and I usually like using
those because they're more ergonomic my
wrists don't hurt but after using this
for a month or two for various things
like my wrists have been fine but yeah I
really like this keyboard I've also got
the wrist like cushioned thing I don't
know what it's called ought to go with
it and that also helps with the comfort
of using this keyboard as well
and before we move on to the next
category just want to talk about the
mousepad that I got its from thank you
Scott got this for me and I like it it's
nice and big and it also doesn't slip
and it's black and it's cool and I like
it and you show too
[Music]
so let's talk monitors so I like having
two monitors on my desk all the time so
I've got one vertical here and the other
ones horizontal the horizontal ones LG
and the other one is Dell
they're both 4k both 27-inch and they've
been great I could go into the specific
specs of each one but to me what's more
important is just clarity they're not
flickering and that they're big enough
and they've been working really well for
me I also like having two separate
monitors instead of one long one because
I find that my focus works better if I
have two different ones and I've pinned
things in different places so yeah not
much to say here about the monitors I
like the ones that I have they don't
hurt my eyes they're big enough they're
great I'll leave this and everything
else as a link in the description box
down below all right so my computer is
like the thing that power is this whole
operation right here I like laptops more
than the stationary computers because I
like being mobile and not being
constrained to my desk right here this
laptop that I have is the exact same one
as the one that I have at work I don't
know which one exactly let me check so
this is a 15-inch MacBook Pro running
Mac OS catallena processor is the 2.9
gigahertz six core Intel Core I nine
about 32 gigs of memory and it's got one
terabyte of storage
I found this laptop although expensive
to be really good because it can keep up
with all the things that I'm running at
work usually I'm running like at least
15 applications at once and because I'm
an iOS engineer I use Xcode the IDE that
Apple created and that takes quite a bit
of memory and CPU to run and this one
does it pretty well it can keep up
really well the only thing about the
15-inch and 16 inch MacBook Pro though
that I don't like is that it's really
hard to find backpacks that fit that
size that I like although I have found
two backpacks that are particularly
liked for my 15-inch MacBook Pro I did
it what's in my backpack video a while
ago but if you'd like an updated one
please let me know in the comments down
below so yeah I use this laptop right
now to edit videos and your emails do
graphic stuff sometimes do a little bit
of development and of course my work one
is like my
main workhorse of a laptop that I do all
the things on and I chose Mac because
I've been using Mac since I was like
five and also I can't not use Mac in
writing iOS applications so these last
couple of items are things that make me
feel a sense of self in my desk and make
me feel like I'm at home
the first of which is lighting so I have
this IKEA lamp I mean lots of light in
my life because I'm from San Diego and
grew up with a lot of light and I like
this one it's minimal it's fine it works
the light is warm and it's good so the
second thing is this coaster which is
actually a Spanish tile piece with some
little fuzzy things at the back this was
the wedding favor that we gave out on
our wedding last year and we've got our
name stamped on the back and yeah it's
just nice it's cozy I like having
posters everywhere and they're pretty
they're great and I like that this one
was a DIY next up is my little plant
buddy I haven't named this plant yet and
I usually name my plant so if you have
any suggestions for plant names leave it
in the comments down below
but yeah I just picked this up the plant
store and I like it
greenery helps me feel calm and chiller
and so I've been wanting something like
that and now I have a friend for my desk
and the last thing is this little
gremlin friend that I have actually met
someone at VidCon who makes these little
things and he made this one for me and I
just like having him out my desk because
it feels like he's cheering me on
as I'm doing work editing videos and
coding and it's nice to have little
friends at your desk with you so those
are all the things on my desk I actually
have a couple more things on my desk
that I didn't cover and they're all
really related to my gaming setup which
I use when I stream on Twitch but I
couldn't really tell you what was on it
cuz Scott set it all up so maybe that'll
be another video for another day all
right so the time has come for me to
talk about my new merch yay so I wanted
to make merch for a long time because
I've had a lot of ideas spinning in my
head of things that I really wanted to
wear and I finally just went for it and
made
and I hope you really like it so the
kind of thing about this whole
sweatshirt is around celebrating the
nuance in life and in coding and in tech
one of the things that I remember about
being an early career software engineer
is that it felt like there was an answer
or opinion on everything and that was
really overwhelming to me because I was
like but I don't know any of it like how
could you know that that the right
solution and that question was always
rattling in my head whenever I was met
with making a decision and as I've
gotten older I've been working for five
years now I realize like there isn't one
right answer the answer depends on so
many different factors so that's kind of
the history and thought behind the
sweater these are my favorite colors
which is why it's very colorful but I
hope you all like it this is enabled in
the March shelf down below so you can go
check that out
but also a link to the store is in the
description box down below and if you
find these tag me let me know follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at Helen will
you go and show me you wear your merch
because I would be so cool like I
literally made this in my room and if I
see other people in the world wearing
this like I don't know that's kind of a
surreal cool feelings so I hope you like
it and thanks for letting me do this I
guess alright that's it for this video I
hope you all have a great day wherever
you are and I'll see you next time bye